they are continuing by the way on the
Republican side to be complete lunatics
when it comes to abortion the latest is
the the Attorney General of Alabama says
women can be prosecuted for taking
abortion pills a report from al.com
one week after the federal government
made it easier to get abortion pills
Alabama attorney general Steve Marshall
said Tuesday women in Alabama who use
those pills to end pregnancies could be
prosecuted that's despite wording writes
al.com in Alabama's new human life
protection act that criminalizes
abortion providers and prevents its use
against the people receiving abortions
instead the Attorney General's office
said Alabama could rely on an older lab
an older law designed to protect
children from meth lab fumes
quote the human life protection act
targets abortion providers exempting
women upon whom an abortion is performed
or attempted to be performed it does not
provide an across-the-board exemption
from all criminal laws including the
chemical endangerment law that's what
they would use to prosecute a woman who
ingests an abortion pill to end a
pregnancy the chemical endangerment law
this is a terrible idea and remember
that Donald Trump thought of this before
Donald Trump understood you're not
supposed to say we go after the women
Donald Trump had this incredible moment
when being interviewed by Chris Matthews
back in this was 2015 or 2016 where he
said yeah you should punish the women
remember this do you believe in
punishment for abortion yes or no as a
principle the answer is that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form 10 cents 10 years now the next day
Donald Trump backed back that he he
walked that back he was told immediately
Donald you're off script we say punish
the doctors we don't punish the women
but this is something that Republicans
have toyed around with for a long time
now when you criminalize abortion you
restrict access to safe and legal
abortion you don't actually limit
abortion and you directly attack the
autonomy and sovereignty that women
should have over their own bodies they
talk about freedom
Liberty Etc except not in this
particular case women should have the
right to make decisions about their
bodies and their own health care the
government shouldn't be able to force
them to carry pregnancies to term
against their will and the idea of
criminally Prosecuting a woman who makes
the decision to take an abortion pill is
really Gilead type stuff Prosecuting
women who takes up who take abortion
pills also puts their health and
well-being at risk because again when
you dissuade women from legal and safe
Medical Services they pursue sometimes
illegal and often unsafe services and by
the way if you care about this which a
lot of them don't these types of laws
always disproportionately affect poor
women
and women of color because I mean listen
you look at in Argentina for example
where abortion was illegal for a long
time you think wealthy women weren't
having safe abortions they were uh but
of course they needed to have the money
for it and this is often the way that
that it goes there seems to be one
Republican who gets that this type of
thing is a bad idea and that's Nancy
mace Nancy mace uh Republican
congresswoman appeared on Morning Joe
when was this uh oh this morning I
believe it was and she said
um it's not really a great thing for
Republicans to be pushing this type of
stuff now just this week the I think it
was the governor of Alabama said that
women should be thrown in prison if they
take an abortion pill so I mean Plan B
is something that 90 of America supports
women shouldn't be thrown in prison
neither should doctors at this juncture
either but one of the things that I've
been harping on this week and for months
now is that if we're gonna get serious
about saving lives right if we were
serious about that issue we have to have
legislation that'll pass a Democrat can
controlled Senate and
republican-controlled House one of the
things that we could do right now is
giving women access to birth control if
you want to get serious about saving now
she is saying all the right things but
the truth is she voted for a lot of this
stuff anyway so she is apparently
recognizing at least for PR purposes
that Republicans should look in a
different direction but when you look at
her voting record it really leaves
something to be desired at the end of
the day this is not something the
American people are increasingly uh
going for and Republicans need to figure
out where do we draw the line in order
to avoid damaging ourselves as they
argue with arguably did to some degree
in the midterms but that's the new one
Alabama's saying we could prosecute
women who take abortion pills we're
going to take a very quick break make
sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel at youtube.com the davidpackman
show plenty more coming up today
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with its fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below